[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm really excited to get to introduce
actually the next two uh presentations
the first by diego
um i'll just say i think i think diego
is doing such
interesting work and we really first
kind of
encountered each other as thinkers last
year in my network culture seminar and i
really started to see
uh diego just pick up in really
interesting ways on intersections of
disciplines you know sort of
on the one hand a little bit being
inspired by some sds stuff but thinking
through kind of
another ways kind of classic media
studies question so i'm really excited
about this thesis because i think it
pulls together
several really interesting threads in a
really unique way
so i hope you enjoy it and i will turn
it over to you diego
uh thank you thank you for the
introduction
let me share my screen
can everyone see it okay
thank you yeah uh well so
this is the the title of my of my my
thesis uh and as it as the title says
it's basically about the intersection of
like media and like
a little bit of like sds and also
probably economic sociology or something
like that so
uh i will take you through this journey
so please bear with me
um
okay so to begin with uh what is the
premium miracle so
uh the premium miracle uh as it has been
defined by
economists is like this period of growth
of gdp growth
between 2002 and 2012
that it was the largest cumulative gdp
growth
per capita in a century in the country
so
um what i'm basically uh referring to
is this the line of
you can see in this chart right it's
like this like
uh really pronounced growth of the gdp
per capita in the country
uh so why i'm
why i'm interrogating this and uh why
i'm
doing this uh from like a media
perspective
uh well there are there are two uh
important facts here and the the first
one is that some people have been
critiquing this idea of like
the miracle actually happening uh mainly
there are different types of critiques
but i i will
like narrow it down to like um
they these these critiques take they
this idea as something that is uh
monolithic and this
this like almost a demonic narrative of
uh we are like growing and everything is
going great
but uh this is not true but like since
this narrative is everywhere
we are like all rightly being dominated
by this idea
uh of course this has come into question
with copy 19 and the pandemic
but this the i my i'm suggesting here
that we can notice this before the
demi right we can notice this before uh
this uh uh crisis and
uh and what what i'm basing
what i'm taking uh as a as a base to
argue this is that
uh through the last uh
four or five years we can notice
that there were some features in the
last two uh
in the last two governments so
what am i doing exactly is kind of like
a detailed description of how
uh this economic narrative is
uh basically in entangled with uh
politics and these are really uh
two different uh there are these these
are not two different
uh things that go each one in the way
but
these are two different these are uh two
aspects of
the same uh of the same coin two phases
of the same point if you want to use up
there
and when we uh notice that
uh we can notice that the string of the
the string of the narrative of the
miracle is
it's it's not it's not that
it's not that great or is is it's not as
solid as it has been argued that it is
and and
and actually if we take a step back and
start to question the
the strength of the narrative we we can
see some cracks and we can see some
features
between uh between actors that
supposedly were on the same side of like
arguing that everything is going great
etc so and what i am not doing
is trying to see if the miracle really
existed
because i'm not into like fact checking
or or
anything like that i'm i'm also not
trying to say that
uh economics is only like a mask for
politics or
uh it's only like an like uh like uh
like a facade
of politics uh i'm arguing that
economics and politics are entangled and
it's kind of like technical on the
social are entangled
and i i'm i'm not also trying to like
uh inter make an interpretation of this
or
like unveiling our an ideology
so and this is kind of like what am i
arguing about like
of course if now we are seeing that uh
the the pandemic crisis has uh struck
peru like really
really hard with like the highest excess
of that per million or
like the the largest uh global economic
crash
and like with economic political and
economic instability
of course seeing that you can you can
say of course this was never
this was never real and it you can see
people
disputing these facts in me in peru
media
but my what i'm suggesting is that if we
if we go back uh we can see that even in
media you can see
that the the narrative of the of the
miracle was never that solid
so uh i i i go back to the
to the to the context and the origins of
the miracle
and uh i i what i do
first in my thesis is to trace back the
miracle but i don't
i don't go to the to the
to the 2002 or like the beginning of the
gdp growth
but i go back to the 90s and that's
because
it's in the 90s where this the
the free market principles of the
premium economy were installed
uh during the authoritarian regime of
alberto fujimori
and and this is and this is when you can
find kind of like
the origins of the miracle in like
international media making association
between like
the catastrophic uh state of the
peruvian economy
uh coming out of the 80s and these
reforms of
uh this free market principles reform
like kind of like
making a as a miraculous recovery of the
of the premier miracle and i'm i i'm
concentrating in
in international media because uh a lot
a lot of the talk in in peru about like
the peruvian
economy being a miracle uh draws from
like
external source of saying like oh here
look how
people like uh economists uh
that that appear in like magazines like
the economies or
um newspapers like the wall street
journal et cetera look at how they see
us look how they talk about us and they
see this like a
a source of legitimacy for what they are
arguing
so basically what i i do at the
beginning is like
how how do we get from from the 90s from
the uh
from the start of the alberto fukimori's
regime uh
to like this story of success and
and like kind of like they're this rack
to reaches
the story as this piece says
so uh i will not go through all the
the the story because that would take a
lot of time but this these were the
findings of
my like this exploration of this uh 22
years of coverage of like
uh the peruvian miracle in in angry
american media
uh first of all is like there is a
narrative
that talks about a subordination of
politics to economics and what i mean by
this is that
uh when uh alberto fujimori
uh takes power he is portrayed as
somebody with a lot of like uh
power to like enact certain changes
in uh in the in the peruvian economy
and make these free market reforms
and by making these free market reforms
he uh kind of like installs uh
economic order that after even after he
leaves uh is the these reforms are not
then changed in the subsequent
governments uh
even though the the the subsequent
govern the subsequent governments were
like
people that were opposed to to
fukimori's government and that's why
i i talk about like uh uh
a subordination of politics to economics
and like
politics um
can can be like changing and everything
but the narrative says that these
all these uh political changes are
subordinated to
uh the economic order and uh and this is
um uh what i mean when i talk about like
a consensus over a decade like the
government of liberty mary uh
lasted uh 10 years and over
over these ten years uh there was uh
it was a consensus was built about what
is the correct way of of managing the
economy
and these pre-economic principles got
entrenched
and uh and they were not longer like
a possible way of like going out of
these economic principles and
uh and even though when there were
there were political moments of
political destabilization
uh these were moments that were
described by this narrative as
this is stabilizing for the economy not
like
for uh the how the population
uh perceive or how the population uh
thought about their own well-being but
all these like
if there were political um um
disruptions they were disruptive for the
economy so
there is always like a like a like a
dominance of
what we are like what we what
this what the economy is doing for uh
sorry for what the politics are doing
for the economy
so like being said that uh
then the the the next step i
is the what theoretical framework i use
to
approach controversies in media because
uh
what what what i what i want to do is
that
okay that we have this narrative about
like how
there is this predominance of of
economics over politics but let's see
how that reflects on
like actual controversies in in
peruvian media and because if
like if one takes this narrative as face
value
if you move to me to media and see
controversies about the economy
one will see one should see that
like there are two clear sides and
people
at the elite uh have a like a
solid argument that they don't make
disputes
or they don't have fights between each
other but they have like a coherent
uh discourse about like why what is
right what is wrong and
what should be rejected uh or what
should not have a space
in in the economic narrative so
uh to approach the controversies that i
analyze in my thesis
i i have like there is a large
theoretical work that i use but i
i want to focus on two points uh the
first one is uh the economy as a
socio-technical construction
and one important thing to notice is
that when we talk about economy we
we mostly talk about gdp and
and this is something that has been uh
studied by a lot of people but
i i take the approach uh by timothy
mitchell
that talks about how uh gdp made
uh possible to actually talk about the
economy
like it gave me like a it turned it into
a discursive object that he
he argues like when we talk about the
economy when we talk about the economy
growing or the the company decreasing we
actually talking about like how gdp
that is this really a specific uh
number that has its audience in like
england
and the united states uh
in the middle of the in the interwar and
the
second world war period uh then
is used uh how this object then is used
to talk about the economy in every other
country in the success
in the subsequent decades right and and
by in
and by talking about the the economy uh
uh one introduces the future as a tool
of course
because we always talk about gdp growing
gdp decreasing
and gdp uh being kind of like this
tool of government of like oh okay if we
if we
take these actions if we take these
measures then
like the economy is going to be in the
future
uh bad or the future and which will be
better
right so uh this this
focus on numbers introduces uh
narratives in in in in
our way of life or what well how we
understand they are not just
numbers uh purely rational numbers but
they are
uh uh as i said like they introduce
the the estimation of or how do we
project
our future is going to be and this is
something that uh michelle murphy calls
a
fantastic and like how these
quantitative practices
are imbued by africa and uh how we
many times uh project our fears and
uh and our expectatives and into
what these numbers tell us about our
future for example
in the case of the gdp and um
the second point that i want to make is
uh about the relationship between media
and uh and expertise
and there there is there are
there is a bunch of literature i'm
talking about this but i
i want to focus on like the role of
expertise and numbers
and i think we
have to understand numbers also as ways
of inter being in the public sphere
not not just like by actual
interventions but just as
producing numbers that are going they
are going to be public are also
ways of intervening apart from like of
course op-eds and interviews etc
so uh
and and also when experts do actual
interventions
like in in media etc
these are uh these are
interventions that are not just a nail
through but
they are made by experts that are given
floor
by by certain media but in certain
places right it's not just
it's not just economic expertise being
dominant by itself
it's like certain economic expertise
being dominant
uh in certain media and this is certain
expertise that is very specific so
this process of like total economization
of our lives has to be
taken with uh more carefully i argue so
the methodological framework that i use
for these controversies are
uh basically basically in sds in science
and sociology of science studies
necessarily
science in knowledge
and i basically i basically uh i take
like an agnostic approach to this
controversy so i don't
like a priori assume there is a there is
a right
and a wrong side but i think uh i want
to see
how their arguments take traction and
uh how they gain traction and how
uh their arguments are finally if
we can use this word successful for the
purposes of the actors that are trying
to mobilize
uh them in media right and
and by by analyzing uh the arguments
that
that these experts and economies are
making
uh i i use uh
to analyze this i use the a framework uh
or a theory known as actor network
theory
in which i i see how i try to see how
these
economies enroll uh allies that and by
and by allies i don't mean like uh just
citing another economies but how do they
enroll
for example a chart or for example a
number
uh these are not uh actors we don't have
to understand actors just as human
actors but also as non-human actors
and and uh
well and why i try why i'm doing this
like why
why i'm like trying to see if if
if the if this is in any sense
meaningful is because
uh there there is uh
there is kind of like an abundant uh
talk about
the economy or the economy or the
the stories of economic success of
stories of economic miracles
in economic literature but
in the other hand uh studies about how
economic miracles and
are portrayed in non-fiction media are
as really scanned
and this is this is something that has
been noticed but
uh people doing his history of social
science
and and and in their and
they they themselves recognize that in
some cases
uh people doing history of social
science
uh tend to like understand really well
like academic debates
debates happening in journals for
example
or like people in in certain
institutions
like but uh but there there is not
enough attention to what
economics is doing in action and in like
in a wider sense right and and this is
something that for example diego mata
argues that
to understand economics and in action we
have to
study media and
uh so i don't i won't go through each of
the controversies because that would be
that will take too much time uh but
uh i i would just describe some
conclusions
and i will take examples from the
controversies
uh the first controversy takes place
from 2016 to 2017.
and uh i in this first
controversy i asked uh how do we
how does media allows political
confrontations to take
a a technical turn in the second
controversy from
january uh 28 2017 to march 2018
my main question is how media separates
uh
expertise in to some somehow valid
expertise and in value expertise but
this
valid or invalid nation are not just
based on technical
uh and technical uh notions
and uh in in 2019
uh this this is the shortest uh
controversy uh i i tried to see how
controversies
uh uh actually
reach a closure because in in the
previous two ones that controversies do
not reach one in
the the third one is actually a
controversy that happens not between
economic uh
experts but kind of like uh journalists
and
business business persons that actually
reaches a uh
a closure so to jump to the conclusions
and lessons because
as i said i will not go through each of
the controls
that will take too much time uh but one
one of the conclusions that i take
after doing this analysis of these
controversies
is that uh what the the role of media in
learning these controversies is
uh in in studying this controversy is
like huge
uh and actually this kind of like goes
back to the point of made by tiago mata
that
to understand economics in action we
have to see how how move
how how argument economic arguments are
being mobilized through media
and and by media i don't mean just
kind of like the technical structures
but i i take this kind of like
inspiration
if you want to if we want to use that
word from this disagreement that
uh media is like technical form but it's
also
associated protocols and for example in
in the case of protocols uh there is
kind of like this discretionary
technopolitical filtering of expertise
that i was referring previously
in which uh is not exercises but
maybe the materiality of media itself
but like by the actors that are that
give floor
or that allow certain expertise to be
or not be in media right so uh
media does not media as general does not
privilege
economic expertise or quantitative
expertise
uh like in in general
either it gives preference to certain uh
economic expertise and to certain
economic uh
experts uh but very specific reasons
right
and and in the
in the in the other side of uh talking
about like
technological forms uh i want to
emphasize the importance of the speed of
media and like
the role of media in these controversies
is
is really it couldn't have happened
the way it happened uh unless uh
it happened in this actual media
ecosystem
and i will i will uh i will point i will
use an
example to illustrate this uh
so uh for example in one one of the
episodes of the
of the of one controversy we can see
that
uh what one of one of the
a minister of economy was using a chart
and and that was trying to portray how
uh deficit was uh growing
from month to month and
and in the following day uh
the the other economist that was the the
former minister of economy who was being
responsibilized by
uh this uh deficit growing and
was making argument about how this chart
was wrong
and by the moment he was making that
argument one
one of the one of the uh
one of the viewers tweeted at the chart
that was used
by the previous uh by the in the
previous intervention but by the other
economist
uh saying like oh you should say that
this chart is wrong
right and and they
the the former the former minister of
economic that was being interviewed live
uh said like oh okay like leave that
chart
there i will explain why that chart is
wrong right
and and uh he proceeded to explain what
this chart is wrong
but i with this example i want to
industry that
this kind of like exchange between uh
arguments and charts and like artifacts
could not have happened if
there wasn't like people watching this
uh
24 hours uh news channel that has
like a twitter account that receives uh
the
the inputs from people viewing the the
discussions and
and with all this kind of like
accelerated media
media ecosystem actually i i argue in my
thesis that brings
uh numbers and this and facts to real uh
to give them enough realness and
why what i use i use this concept that i
take from john law
that uh by by making
certain certain appearances and gaining
certain speed these numbers and facts
actually uh gain enough realness to
to to and to be used
as some as a justification for certain
economic policies um
for for the next lesson and uh
and and this is kind of like an an
important one
it's like i try to conceive uh the
miracle
as a socio-technical narrative
and what what i'm trying to say with
this is that
uh these are not
lies or like kind of like just something
that
um is made up right
uh that just like gains a speed against
realness through circulation in media
but what i'm trying to argue with this
is that there these are
actually like entities that require
technical knowledge technical work
and that are created with like
the involvement of an assemblage of like
persons and
techniques and materiality and that they
are portraying and they circulate
through
actual technological networks and
it and this is this is for this is all
to say that
i conceive them as social technical
non-fictions at something that is
not like real as the reflection of
what is out there but they are neither a
fiction as like something that is
not real like just made up actually
these are
something in between in the trashy in
the transition from one state to another
and to put it in in a certain way
uh and but by
by by saying this is that and one
important consequence of saying this is
that
the the uh is if mitchell was saying
that
introducing these socio-technical
non-fictions
uh to government is actually introducing
the future as government
uh it actually it actually also
introduces
i i argue effective states as a school
of government
because our our hopes are our
our our dreams if you will and our
our fears about like what is going to
happen with the economy in the in the
future
are also affected but by these kind of
socio-technical nonfictions that are
that are constructed by these larger uh
processes of circulation of information
and and here's another example of this
is
uh and it may look like really
convoluted but
uh these are typical material that
uh happened to appear in this type of me
in this type of publication
of business uh that are actually
projections
and there is so there is a lot of talk
about projections and estimations
and but these estimations and
projections are not just made
following a pure calculation
but they are actually they are actually
bets and they are actually
um kind of like uh
hopes of also of the of the people
making them and
and and i'm not like just making this
up and this is actually what these
people said like
people say like my projection is this
because i'm betting that
this is going to happen because i'm
betting that this is going to happen
or because i am hoping that this is not
going to
to to take place right and for example
in one of the projections in the top was
was made by hoping that in 2017 there
was not going to be floods in peru
and what happened there were the largest
flocks in like three decades
so and and also
like there was a projection later in
another
moment there was a projection of this is
a projection of what is going to of what
gdp growth is going to be
if the president is not impeached what
happened then the president was
impeached
and then the next president two years
later was also impeached so and
so all this all this it all this is to
say oh well and then there is also this
poles that
also uh always
measure the optimism of the people kind
of like the mood
of the coming of the economy who want to
call it that way
that are not actually like
are not actually based in something
real like in the sense of like something
that is out there but it's
actually the the the fears or or the
concerns that people have
right so but these are actually taken
into account by other people to make
projections
so what i'm trying to say with this is
that we should be careful uh
of like assigning a technique a just
have
technical power to to to the to these
actors
that use these numbers and we should
we should be aware that they are they
are kind of like
using uh what i call like as
technosocial bricklash
of like something that involves
calculations but also
that involves fears concerns etc
and the the third conclusion in the
lesson is that
uh this talks about like assigning power
to certain actresses and and
uh as observer through through the lens
of media uh
these economic experts appear appear
to be in this array like they are
disputing each other they are fighting
each other every time and
they are not like a monolithic uh
collective or a monolithic
uh consensus of like people having the
the very same uh narrative about what is
happening right
even if there are supposedly just facts
and supposed to just technical details
and so so and what i'm trying to say
with this is like as
researchers we we should have to be a we
should
acknowledge how uh
uh how the how we conceive the objects
of our interrogation
and a priori assuming certain certain
like
strengths or say a certain level of
uh of like power in people and or
enactors
uh it's not only kind of like from a
political standpoint of course
uh deficit deficits but but it's also
kind of like demonstrates that
perhaps we are not being like um
we are not interrelating this object or
these narratives
like in a more detailed way right so
uh well and this is something that has
been argued like for
for four decades it's not something that
i just made up
and and one one way to escape this is
ask along michelle colomba to argue is
that
we should probably situate ourselves as
researchers
not like and just in the level of
macro social of like just like
ideologies and narratives
and and like institutions and but
neither at the level of just actors
because like institutions actually exist
and
they have consequences right but we
should we should be aware of like
how these processes from yeah from from
of movements of like
from macro social to microsocial app
and uh and this is this is for example
one
this is the last uh example concrete
example that i have
and this happened in one of the one of
the controversies that i analyzed
um and the the
the minister of economy in that time in
2016
uh kind of like spread some
rumors about his predecessor and
when he was confronted he instead of
like
instead of like going outside and like
or
fighting out giving a formal
communication
he he made a facebook status in his
personal
facebook account and then this
was screenshoted and then was
posted in the official twitter account
of the ministry of of of economy
and then there was like this large uh
twitter thread just like posting threads
from
the personal profile from this person
like say apologizing oh well it was a
very bad apology
but but by doing this kind of like
all the all the kind of like power of
like this institution the ministry of
economy that was
conceived as this very powerful entity
that
like put like really well-defined
uh economic rules and economic order in
the country
sort of like falls apart and you can see
that actually
it's a really precarious entity in the
sense of that
the the this this mystical bale of
like power uh is not that real and
it's actually kind of like in the hands
of people that are willing to
to to use it for personal reasons right
so in this sense the the people that
were being accused of the the rumors
point about like
his predecessors installing people by
just not following technical criteria
but uh
by by political orders following
political orders
kind of like reverse and the people that
that were making the accusations that
we're using rumors actually were
kind of like more in the political side
rather than the technical side that
actually
in in the past follow it kind of like
this mystic of like
of the narrative of the economic miracle
and uh as a final
uh and this is my final uh
uh lesson conclusion uh
and this relates to the previous one is
about the power of the economy and
uh and talking about the economy as
something
that has a powerful explanatory uh force
kind of like
uh operates certain uh actions and
and forces that take place between uh
actors
and and oh and here i'm i'm
i'm quoting uh by saying that maybe it's
not
that we should kind of like use power as
expiratory force but we should probably
try to explain how power came to be like
by following these processes of like
how actors invoke the power of like
institutions
or how they evoke the power of certain
forces and and
by making the by tracing these movements
of like from macro social to microsocial
what they call translation is how we
should probably give a better
explanation than just
uh than just like turning to
like power or like ideology or or
certain other objects that are usually
found by in in
in in social science research and and
this actually
kind of like also goes in hand with
murphy
michelle's murphy explanation that um
mrs martin argument that the economy
is not that what should
do why should the economy is that which
must be explained it's not
which stats display um
and and that's all that's that's all i
have
thank you
all right thank you let's open it for
questions
yeah william yeah so diego thanks that's
that's exciting and i mean like your
last slide is like totally
on the money um
how economists have been able to sort of
stand outside as a
as a priesthood and exempt themselves
from like
everything that's happening in social
science is beyond my comprehension
and they do it and i guess it's because
when you think about
what the value of a bitcoin is or what
the value of your
retirement portfolio in stocks is it's
quantified belief it's nothing more or
less than quantified belief you know to
the second or third decimal point
uh futures are nothing but that kind of
hope and belief
um so so just to say a big a big yes
i put a note in there that you were
talking about the the in the 90s the
shift from a kind of
the way in which uh economic discourse
overrode or or a political there's a
political shift but the same kind of
economy
economic logic the truth of numbers
prevails and made a note that said yeah
there seems to be a shift from
from words the power of words to the
power of numbers
and and just to to think through this
technosocial
ensemble um it's also like the 90s when
the internet becomes
kind of actualized i mean it's around
before obviously has a deep history but
but really kind of pervasive and with
that
spread um my guess and this is pure
conjecture my guess is that um
you know the multinational finance firms
the notions of expertise really goes
global
fast and and that discourse of numbers
and that disaggregation of
a kind of priesthood of numbers from the
the political engagement with you know
whatever whatever passes is truth in
their world
that's i think is writ large across the
planet we see
the same thing happening in the u.s in
the switch from
bush to to clinton where clinton
basically maintains
shift in social policies for sure but
the economic
uh stance i mean clinton could have been
a republican in a way
you see the same thing happening in
britain with blair when he follows up
with john
the the the thatcherite john major thing
blair keeps that that you know we can i
look back i would call it neoliberalism
but in fact maybe it's about a kind of
expertise professionalization
uh a separation at that level
level that's enabled by global flows of
a very particular kind of knowledge
the ability to model this stuff on a fly
because you could kick up the graphics
right away
you you know you're trading with kinds
of information you never would have had
in real time let's say in the 1980s
so i'm just wondering if that technology
that prote to be very literal about it
if that kind of technology the the
internet
um is is a factor here
uh yeah i i will i will say that
it has a lot of a lot of literature so
uh i i will say that the kind of like
spreading or like putting notions in
circulation
wouldn't have happened without the the
power of like
this economic network and and for
example
uh there there is a lot of like
influence from
like people doing this reforms in in in
certain places
uh from um
uh i i believe universities etc
right and but these this in the past or
probably
in 80s 90s had to be like brought
by certain actors specific actors right
but but now what we have is like this
these uh numbers or these rankings
actually ranked in some ocean are also
important here
just going straight from from from
from from the north to the south like as
as soon as they
as as soon as they are they are out like
uh
you you name it it's like the the
ranking of like
which countries the more has the more
free or the freer economy and
as soon as you come out in in north and
you have it improved
and uh instantly right so i would say
that
of course that there is as we
become more connected in like in the
world
literally in the world the the the the
power of these numbers and
and these rankings and these notions is
because it's
growing ever it's ever growing at least
that's that's my take and that's also i
i think something that we we can
actually take from my thesis
i don't like i don't make that extra
argument
because i don't make i i don't study the
the circulation
precisely in the internet but i would
say that as this networks become like
ever growing the the probably
the probabilities that these notions and
these
numbers become ever more powerful
other questions
deal okay hi um
[Music]
it's i i really love the ambition of
this work do you go sorry the doctors
dog decided to come here i really love
the ambition of this work and trying to
sort of bring together media studies
with sts and so i have
maybe a reductionistic question but i'm
curious like
after going through this whole process
are you able to like
what do we gain by like maybe thinking
in terms of the non-human
these things as non-humans rather than
just
media representations like is there
something about that
liturian sts language that you find you
would sort of distill as particularly
generative
or would you actually not use the
non-human language for for someone
for some of this stuff uh
one one of the i think one one of the
ways i try to use the
the the notion of the non-human actors
is that
it's not only uh it's not only
uh other economies having authority
outside that are
brought into the discretions but are
actually
numbers themselves and charts and all
these like
non-human devices actually
uh that came into into circulation
and by by i don't i don't want to say
that by themselves because because they
circulate through
actually social technical assemblages
is that these these non-human entities
gain power and gain traction so
uh i would say that that's that's the
most kind of like
how i approach to this uh to this topic
from that
from that perspective is that we
probably should take into account the
power of these
social technical entities if we want to
name it that way
uh as having as having kind of like
this uh as coming into reality
not necessarily by because they are
named
by these really famous economies
specific economies in
in like in a global north country but
because they circulate
through some networks uh and these
networks are also an assemblage of like
not only human persons but also
uh kind of like larger
larger networks of like enterprises
and companies and also and also humans
right so
i would say that having this this uh
this notion uh really present
or having it really into account
actually
uh let us see that this is this is
bigger than
or this is something else that just a
discussion between
just one person versus another person
but this is like one person
invocating a network of of allies that
probably are humans and probably are not
uh and
other other actors invocating another
network of allies kind of like
uh going against each other
all right thank you